[Music]
today we are going to be making
some bread now i've tried making bread
multiple times in the past but each time
i've tried i've managed to make
dough bricks basically it's like
non-edible dough bricks is what i
have always managed to make when i make
bread and now those two times i've ever
tried making bread i've gotten so
discouraged that i haven't really tried
since and this is like maybe like three
years ago so anyways today i'm gonna be
trying to make bread again
and not just any bread one of my
favorite breads of all time breads
today i'm going to be trying to make a
childhood favorite of mine so back in
dallas where i'm from there
is a fast food homestyle cooking
restaurant
they serve comfort food and i think
they're mainly based in the south
because i've never seen one here in l.a
it's called grandes they're known for
their fried chicken they're known for
a country fried steak but the true star
menu item that they had
was their dinner rolls and their dinner
rolls were like these
it wasn't your typical dinner roll and i
can compare them to the hawaiian rolls
that you would find at your typical
grocery store but they're still not
comparable to that
it's sweeter it's softer it's honer than
your typical hawaiian sweet roll these
dinner rolls at grannies were
out of this world like nothing compares
to randy's dinner rolls
and the sad thing about us granny's
actually slowly going out of business
like they don't have that many locations
anymore so the last time
i went back to dallas we went to a
granny's i introduced tiff to
the fried chicken there and of course
the dinner rolls and it's just been in
my mind to like i should try to recreate
these dinner rolls and
um for the past six months i've been on
the internet trying to find
a recipe where they replicated this but
you know what it's a harder recipe to
find than you would expect
in fact there's no specific grandes
recipe out there right now no one's even
calling it like
the replicated like the copycat version
of it i found a lot of golden honey
yeast rolls
recipes such as this one right here
golden honey yeast rolls and i've had to
go to some random forms to find these
so-called grandy's dinner roll recipes
and i found about like three different
recipes that claim that they're close to
a granny's recipe
but i get to try them and i figured
today is as good as any day to try to
make some dinner rolls you know it's
early afternoon now so i think if i time
it all properly it should be dinner time
by the time i'm done with this
and we should have some awesome dinner
rolls for dinner i'm craving some
granny's dinner rolls right now all
right so here we have the usual suspects
when it comes to baking
bread got some eggs salt oil milk
honey for the honey yeast rolls so
flour obviously but honey and yeast and
i want to talk about this yeast so i for
some reason
can't understand how yeast works like
i've got the temperature right and
everything but
it just doesn't rise i guess i'm going
to keep trying this until i get it right
but
if those of you guys out there know how
to bake and make bread watch this video
let me know what i'm doing wrong because
i can't seem to get my dough to rise
that's my
biggest problem right now so i actually
hope these are still good i don't know
if there's an
expiration date and there is says uh
may 2020 so this is one year ago
well hopefully these expiration dates
aren't exactly
um accurate and hopefully uh that's
still good to go
i'm optimistic i feel good about this
one plus it's honey yeast rolls so i
i like the factor of you know having
more fat
in this recipe and then having the
sweetness
of the honey so i feel good about this
[Music]
one
okay moment of truth looks pretty good
looks like it's being activated
[Music]
i don't know if it's supposed to be this
[Music]
sticky
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so i think that was pretty
good uh
i can feel the consistency of the dough
and it feels like it's gonna rise and
it's gonna
puff up and all that good stuff so yeah
i've covered it put it in the oven got
the lemon light on because it's supposed
to
increase the temperature just a little
bit to keep it warm to rise better
in the meantime i'm going to start
editing because
i got deadline that i got to meet
[Music]
and before i forget thank you soundcore
for sponsoring today's video now i spend
a lot of time editing videos to really
gauge the audio when you're editing you
have to have decent
quality headphones so soundcore sent me
their live q35 to test while i'm editing
my videos
these headphones have great active noise
cancellation you can choose from
indoor outdoor or even transport mode
transport meeting while you're on an
airplane the audio quality is actually
really really good man i'm yelling and
it includes this technology called
ldaf audio coding which means you can
have high def audio over bluetooth and
the best thing about these headphones is
you get 40 hours of battery life while
using noise cancellation or 60 hours
without the noise cancellation it lasts
forever and it only takes five minutes
to charge
and even better yet they're only a third
of the price of headphones from larger
brands
so soundcore q35 is an affordable option
for all your video editing needs so
check them out in our link below
all right it's been an hour we've been
letting this thing rise
let's see how it looks
[Music]
oh no it didn't rise did it rise or did
it not rise
i can't tell i don't think it rose new
all right we're supposed to smash it in
well
did it rise i can't tell now i'm scared
now now i'm worried that we're not gonna
have randy's
dinner rolls for tonight
[Music]
all right so i have waited countless
hours i don't know how many hours like
two three hours uh three phases of
letting the dough rise and each time i'm
looking at the dough
doesn't seem like it rose very much
they'll say you know if you poke it into
the dough
it'll like bounce back a little bit and
that's a good sign so it did do that but
it doesn't seem like it's raising a
whole lot
and then now that i've formed the balls
to make it into like the actual dinner
rolls now it's supposed to
puff up and rise and fill up the entire
like
baking pan now i'm nearing the end of
this last
and final rise show you what i'm looking
at here it doesn't seem like it's gonna
expand too much more than that it does
smell pretty good though it smells like
what it's supposed to smell like it
smells like dinner rolls but
it's not expanding and it's supposed to
have like that whole pull-apart effect
you know where it's like all like
smooshed together and you pull it apart
and you're like oh how fluffy the dinner
rolls are
yeah i don't think i'm gonna get that
effect today tell me what i did wrong
and you know what i think i know what it
is i think it's the uh
expired yeast that i'm using it's like
one year past its expiration date but
i don't know all right so i guess it did
expand a little bit
it definitely looked bigger than when
they first went in and
they're touching on the sides barely
barely just a few of them all right so
maybe not a complete fail still feeling
pretty good about this i guess
uh just started dinner it's about that
time of the night
and uh prince isaac requested
some pasta so i got some pretty instant
stuff going on here
in the meantime all right this is this
is the uh
the glory of the night all right
temperature's up
370 in goes the buns which
actually in the time that i've been
waiting for the oven to preheat
they've actually increased in size so
hey
maybe the oven actually being on and
making this room hotter making the
kitchen hotter
actually help the yeast go into action
or something alright
and it goes
hey siri set timer for
16 minutes 16 minutes
[Music]
all right they are done i don't know how
i feel
about this they don't look like dinner
rolls to me
it did puff up a lot i don't what is it
spotting what is going
on what did i do wrong looks like bread
smells like bread touch it it's a little
harder than you'd expect
dinner roll to be so it's not very
fluffy
but it's also not a brick it's not
stones
of dough like i did last time so much
better
i would say let it cool down i guess
we'll eat it for dinner we'll find out
what happens
[Music]
i haven't tried it yet huh
it doesn't make any sense i know all
right so in our house we have this
i i started doing this thing where i'm
like i just kind of like use the base of
my voice
uh and i say food's ready because base
travel is more than
you know like if you it's ready it
doesn't really travel through the house
so i kind of bellow it out and uh and
then
isaac where does your phrase come from
so i say food's ready and then isaac
always responds with what you get so
it's like a
like a made-up phrase yeah yeah it says
one of these spanish
um look at them like that's not even a
word
i like it though i like it now it's like
a it's like a slogan of our
of our house now but now you're adding
on you're adding on foods daddy
yeah cause he has mom's games isaac
plays
oh right something i regret not like
having documented more specifically is
all the sayings you've had throughout
the years isaac like uh
that's the suga or you used to say
that's disgusting
a lot too yeah these are all from like
memes and stuff right
yeah yeah oh you want to try it yeah all
right
be my guest you guys are my guinea pigs
i i haven't even tried it yet it doesn't
look that great
wow really they're good that's right
they look good they look good and they
taste good no
way you guys are joshing me here
really think about yourself okay all
right it's got a nice little
nice little texture going on all right
here we go moment of truth
not bad not what i was going for
but it's super edible and it's actually
pretty good for what it is i think the
last time you made bread
was an improvement from this time but
that same like density
of the bread it was way worse last time
you did it
i made bricks yeah it was like a brick
but this is actually like
it's like a breath
but not shabby the next time you make it
it'll have a lot less of that like
dense i hope so i'm sure it's fine we're
not gonna
get sick and die or anything like that
but the yeast i used was a year old
pacific expression
yeah i use honey in it it's a honey
yeast roll yummy
yeah it's supposed to be a lot fluffier
a lot more fluffier
but good job i could eat this
not bad not bad okay
oh